1989 l'opéra bastille est inaugurée en
grande pompe mais ne fait pas
l'unanimité comme bâtiments tous les
genres âge et concentré
le projet était déjà contesté bien avant
son aboutissement en 1984 dès la
présentation de la maquette
il a fallu convaincre des riverains un
stand d'information et même installés
dans les couloirs du métro
le chantier traîne immobilisé par un
mois de grève au plus haut niveau c'est
la valse des directeurs
le projet devient de plus en plus floue
et la facture de plus en plus aller en
1986 avec la cohabitation mitterrand
chirac
le nouveau gouvernement envisage même de
ne plus faire un opéra met une salle de
spectacle et il apparaît c'est difficile
de risque et de dépenser 2 ou 300
millions supplémentaires par an pour
faire un nouvel opéra alors que nous
avons la plus belle salle du monde est
palais garnier remettre en cause ce
projet serait à la fois un désastre
financier et un désastre culturel
il y aura bien du lyrique en 1989 dans
l'enceinte de verre et d'acier sur la
place de la bastille avec les
technologies acoustique n'est plus
sophistiqués à quelques jours de
l'inauguration officielle
un public test est invitée parmi lequel
cette grande amatrice d'opéra
moi j'ai trouvé que l'acoustique était
très métallique c'était un son
métallique ce n'était pas un sombre rond
ce n'était pas un son qui était bien
moelleux quelques critiques aussi de la
part de jack lang très attaché au projet
ça se passe chez vous
à vous de lui
très beau
on s'est allumée place yeux
c'est maintenant un peu à peu blafard le
13 juillet 1989
la fête ne sera pas entachée autour de
françois mitterrand 30 chefs d'état et
2000 invités sont dans la grande salle
de l'opéra d'hasting le moment est
historique il ouvre les festivités du
bicentenaire de la prise de la bastille
[Musique]